Elon Musk is now promoting Q Anon they
say since 2018 the saying follow the
white rabbit has become synonymous with
Q Anon musk has tweeted a version of
that what year 2018.
is that what I said uh so Elon Musk
tweeted follow and then a bunny Emoji
it's an Alice in Wonderland reference he
he history started in 2018 though well
of course yeah I mean that's when the
simulation began we just have false
memories and planted on us the only
explanation so uh this is where we're
currently at let me put it this way let
this be a tremendous white pill
the media is so desperate so panicked
the corporate process so Panic to go
after Elon Musk they have to take this
follow and a rabbit emoji which could be
a matrix reference and then try and
claim he's promoting Q Anon oh dude it's
amazing they may as well just say he
started gamergate at this point yeah
that was Elon history started in 2018
like you were saying it's like they
don't have nothing to attack him on so
they're just starting to make things up
out of nowhere to generate clicks that
is exactly the case I mean think if
you're in their position this is like a
nightmare scenario
yeah right I mean it's all I mean you've
seen the Twitter files coming out and
all that uh I mean it's it's everything
that we knew but now it's obviously been
uh substantiated through these Twitter
files and I mean I I'm sure they are
freaking out
um so yeah I mean they're gonna throw
anything at the wall that can stick but
does anybody buy this
it's like just the insanity I mean do
they all know they're lying you're like
every single one of these Twitter
leftists they're like yeah that's right
it's queuing on like they have to know
their line I imagine there's some
there's a portion of them that believe
it you know just like they're a portion
of on the right that believe whatever
crazy thing you know anyone could come
up with from from the right but I think
mostly it's a functional way to smear
Elon Musk it's just you know spaceship
man bad right now because of this
article they're going to put in his
Wikipedia page he's a conspiracy
theorist who promoted Fringe theories
blah blah blah they'll go ahead and
they'll they'll it'll be ideal
laundering you know he puts up the White
Rabbit so they say that it's queuing on
and then someone else will say it's Q
Anon referencing that just like they do
you know ideal laundering and reference
each other and then next thing you know
what it goes into is is Wikipedia and
Elon Musk is then you know the Q Anon
space that's a great saying Spaceman
Space shipment
I'm tweeting that take a look at this
story this one's really really funny
Daily Mail says breaking news Twitter
has stopped paying rent on San Francisco
offices as Elon Musk considers not
paying Severance to act axed employees
now when you hear that you're like whoa
whoa that's crazy
let me let me break it down for you it
says Twitter has allegedly not paid rent
on its San Francisco headquarters or
office around offices around the world
for weeks
week it's been it's it's been December
for two weeks yeah so he hasn't paid
rent for weeks yeah because you pay on
the first I I haven't either oh no I
haven't paid my mortgage in a month
because it's due the end of the month
it's like oh it's been it's been three
weeks this is the level of insanity for
smearing Elon it doesn't matter if it's
news or not it's just can we make can we
create a narrative that sounds negative
it's so weird
they just I mean it's not that weird if
you think remember remember the way that
that any way any time a negative
headline could be written about Trump
they did the the koi pond thing you know
it's any time you can write a negative
headline they edited video footage to
make that story right yep so the koi
Bond thing Trump is hanging out with
Shinzo Abe Abe dumps the food in and
then Trump goes okay and then dumps his
in as well but they zoom in so you only
see Trump and then said haha what an
idiot he threw all the food in and then
when you look at the unedited video you
can see he was just following Shinto
Abe's lead and they made up a fake story
but they actually tried to make up some
decorum violation with this it's just
like he hasn't paid rent in weeks and
they all start saying it and then I'm
seeing this from everybody they were
like in weeks
is he doing a weekly lease on his
buildings he pays Weekly right what's
your point I don't understand but but
Tim you know Trump was also bad because
he had two scoops of ice cream if you
remember that I mean that was some
serious uh ethics violations right there
and I think he also walked into some
toilet paper I mean and that's a guy
that needs to be stopped and he had
bigger salt and pepper shakers oh you
see that
that's amazing and there are people who
say to this day Trump never denounced
white supremacists and neo-nazis I yeah
I know that you're right and it just
blows my mind
the the that the video of him saying
that is out it exists it's out there and
and it has been put onto Twitter saying
oh he never
condemned them in response so many times
and they still oh he never did there are
still people I meet where I say did you
know that Joe Biden said if you don't if
you don't find the prosecutor you're not
getting a billion dollars they go that
never happened that absolutely happens
it's a video he says it's literally in a
in a like Think Tank press conference on
foreign relations with Richard Haas the
president of the Council of our relation
sitting there literally talking to him
on record on video and he's like and
people applaud but Rachel Maddow said it
wasn't real and so people just believe
whatever she says without even bothering
to to look
yeah that's that's it's a crazy reality
man
that's that that it's one of the
contributing factors to my simulation
Theory there's no way a functioning
sentient being would would just be like
you know I don't know if it's true but
it must be you know who do you know who
uh this is a bit of an off topic but do
you know who Adam and sich are they're
YouTubers they make they do a stream
show anyways they have this they talk
about this idea that most people
basically have the existence of like an
elephant and a rider and the Elephant is
your emotion and the rider is kind of
your brain that like makes the actual
decisions the writer can't really
control the elephant the elephant's
gonna go where the elephant wants to go
right if you're the rider on top of an
elephant you're you're kind of doing
what the elephant you hope that you can
convince the elephant to do what you
wanted to do but the elephant is still
going to do what it wants to do the
fight or flight like you can think but
if you're scared you're gonna fight or
flight
the guy on top thinks he's in charge but
he's not really he's the rider he's
actually kind of just the PR department
explaining rationalizing what the
elephant did so really most of our life
is our our cognitive ability
rationalizing the emotional reactions
that we have that's like most of the the
stuff that we you know most of our
behavior all the time here's the crazy
thing about the story is that 20 years
ago
it would all just be true you'd have no
way of checking it a newspaper would
write Elon Musk promotes Fringe
conspiracy theory and then you'd be like
must be true yeah that's it that's right
um you mentioned Rachel Maddow and we
did talk about body doubles is Chris
Hayes her body double no Michael
Knowles's okay
we actually have uh Smokey Mike right
okay Mike we have uh we have drawings of
all of our guests and so when Michael
Knowles came Jessica the artist here
Drew Rachel Maddow first yeah and so
we're like here when you sign this
picture of you when he hands he started
laughing he saw
[Laughter]
nsnbc is is rated as fake news by
newsguard I am not surprised at all and
it's they should be and I will say I
know it's not a silver bullet but when
you're visiting your family for
Christmas or whatever you can at the
very least pull up on a browser or if I
don't know if there's a mobile app and
be a like guys
I don't know what you believe or why I'm
not going to argue with you I just want
you to know that News Guard says MSNBC
is beware it's fake news okay and
they're gonna go yeah well that was Fox
News and you can go uh-huh yeah I don't
know whatever I'm just telling you you
guys are watching weird conspiracy
garbage I'm not here to tell you what's
right or wrong I'm telling you be
careful with the weird conspiracy stuff
you're watching I was telling a friend
of mine he was like my family just
watches all his MSNBC and CNN and I was
like here's what you do when you're
talking you say I don't know about all
that political stuff if they start
bringing it up and be like guys you're
listening to Alex Jones and all this
stuff and when they invariably get
really really angry because they hate
Jones what you're trying to do is
conflate in their mind what they think
of as conspiracy in a way they
understand it and accusing them of doing
exactly the same thing yeah so you just
like I would play it off like look I
don't know who Rachel Jones or whatever
it's that weird conspiracy garbage
you're watching on the TV there's that
that News Guard thing they said it was
conspiracy stuff and you're watching it
and then they get let them get all
flustered and just be like I don't I
don't know you guys go watch your weird
alien stuff your your lizard people
stuff I'm not I'm not interested it
makes me wish I had in-laws to go and
upset and then
and then when no one is watching no one
paying attention secretly put on died
suddenly and then act like you didn't do
it yourself but but more importantly
especially with the holiday season I
think we should expand on this topic
just a little bit before continuing on
the conversation here but but I think if
you truly do want to understand somebody
you got to do it from an empathetic kind
of way you gotta kind of understand
where they're coming from you got to
kind of listen to them and then you
could formulate a kind of response there
taking some time but you can only open
the door you could only uh you know put
out the water the horse has to drink it
themselves so I I think that's you know
my two cents when it comes to dealing
with family members who don't see eye to
eye to eye with you uh empathy and
understanding goes a long way also just
listening to people goes a very long way
and then you can understand why people
believe a certain idea a lot of it is
usually based on fear a lot of it is
usually based on kind of instincts and
emotions as you were mentioned you're
mentioning um and and not logical
thinking and if you could you could calm
down the emotions and you could not have
that kind of aggressive stance and you
could just say hey let's let's actually
reassess this maybe at a different time
or hey I don't know what to think about
this what do you think about this uh and
giving people that kind of information
that way could be a lot more conducive
towards waking people up towards the
true reality of this world rather than
the conceived closed notion that of
course the government wants them to have
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time